uh welcome everyone uh to this 9 A.M
talk uh uh my name is Maxim Solomon
sharier I'm a Belgian consultant trainer
facilitator living in France I'm working
for a company called Art link
and I'm quite into domain-driven design
architecture and I'm a live and storming
early adopter as well
I'm also co-organizing a conference in
Paris new crafts you can go to and
crafts.io to have some more information
we started to announce our first speaker
and this include Mr Kent Beck so we're
quite excited about this Edition
we have great Workshop as well you can
have a look it will be on May 25th and
26th I'm also part of the virtuality
team so that's a website where you can
go with virtualdd.com and you will find
a lot of different uh videos and
interesting stuff about DDD and I'm also
a DDD crew
contributors so you can find me on
Twitter and masterland on those handle
Nick
to you hey I'm Nick I recommend
recognize some faces in here so good to
see you again lots of new faces as well
similar to Max I work as a consultant in
the space of architecture domains teams
in that area unlike Max I'm not crazy
enough to organize a conference so yeah
that's that's one thing that
differentiates us
and also the co-organizer of a meet-up
that's about my level
meet ups meeting up once a month yeah I
could do that but
all that organizing stuff not my thing
so if you're into these topics in this
talk and you want to learn more you're
always welcome to come to the Meetup and
we're always looking for people to share
their experiences
um around these topics so yeah always
happy to host you
let's talk about today yeah so if you
want to have independent teams with fast
flow in your organization
they will need to work on the Loosely
coupled software architecture because if
all your teams are working on the same
big monolith where the the code is a
tangled mess well they might not be that
autonomous or fast anyway so
um but that's not that's not the
only the the only thing that you need to
to have actually the software
architecture also needs to have Loosely
coupled subdomains and so your you you
will first have to identify those
different boundaries to to have your low
syncopal subdomains and then your
architecture will be aligned to those
subdomains but Nick can you tell us a
bit more about this how to reach that
fast flow yeah sure so
a lot of a lot of the companies we work
with nowadays have read a book called
teens apologies and they're interested
in this stuff called value streams and
stream online teams and all that space
um but it's a little it's a there's a
little bit more to the picture than that
as Max was talking about this is kind of
the ideal Vision what we want to get to
and here are the different pieces that
we need to have in place um to get there
so a value stream is basically
a sequence of steps a team goes through
to identify new product features and
ideas in a particular subdomain
and deliver those as working software in
production adding new features to the
product and there's this concept of fast
flow that everyone's talking about
nowadays what that basically means is
people can get their work done easily
and not be blocked so it's quite a
simple concept really so we just need to
get these things aligned up
if we can Define our domain boundary as
well teams will be able to implement new
features without requiring coordination
with other teams which we know is
expensive
in addition we want each team to have
some specific outcomes they're working
towards normally connected to a product
North Star
so before team's apologies one of the
common approaches is what's called a
feature Factory management has an idea
someone outside the team has an idea the
team's given some requirements and the
team builds two specifications what
they've been told to build in this
modern approach it's the teams
themselves deciding what to build
shaping their own product roadmap
and then the fourth part at the end as
Max talked about is the software for
teams that have fast flow
they need to be able to take those ideas
they found in their area of the business
in their sub domain and to be able to
make those changes in software without
the coordination so if all of these
things are aligned we can get to that
nice world of fast flow just just one
caveat really
it's never possible to have this perfect
scenario where every team's perfectly
independent and they can make every
single change without talking to other
teams
now what we're trying to get at here is
as to reduce as much of the coupling as
we can to have the best best flow
possible you know I do sometimes end up
in situations where people feel like
this is achievable across the whole
company like I was in a workshop
uh around about July last year I think
it was and I was helping these teams
there are four teams working together
and one of the developers said well
I'm working in my team and my team's got
our objectives
but I've also got this other team who
needs us to make some changes for them
how do I privatize my work and I said to
him
well that's one to think about your
product strategy maybe let's talk to the
the CEO of the company it was quite a
small company so not huge
so we got the CEO in the room and we
said you know what's the top priority
here
focus on what the team's doing or help
the other team to achieve their goals
and the CEO said you should reorganize
the software and the team so that there
are no dependencies and this problem
doesn't exist so that's not really
achievable but we can't we can get you
know we can make some big improvements
by drafting our boundaries well and
making sure our software is aligned so
just setting some expectations there
and how do we get there
uh yeah so that's what we are going to
talk about so first of all we need to to
identify those domain boundaries and we
will do that and explain how we can do
that with even storming
um then uh we'll try to refine those
boundaries and make sure they are
realistic and they they fit with our
domain and we will show you how to do
that with a domain message flow modeling
and then at the end uh we'll try to
validate those uh using uh the bound
context canvas so that's the the talk
structure today
please yeah and so we thought since
there are two of us we can try and bring
some role play into this talk to try and
give a sense of what this might look
like in reality obviously an
oversimplification right I'm this I'm
the CEO
so we've had a
had a recent quarterly catch up with the
board
we've looked at the landscape we've been
using a technique called worldly mapping
not covered in this talk and we can see
lots of competitors moving into our
space
um we're going to have to start
innovating much faster now you know we
haven't been going quickly enough and it
looks like we're going to need to double
the company in the next five years
double our Revenue in the next five
years so we're looking at you as the CTO
to you know get us on the right tracks
bring us back to the level of
competition we need to compete yeah sure
sure you forget about we have a big mama
lit right now and that will be quite
hard maybe to to have those uh great
speaking to you I'll speak to you soon
when you've made some programs yeah yeah
sure sure okay
thanks a lot so well I definitely
definitely need to go see my principal
engineer to see if he has some good
ideas uh yeah so we have to double uh
the revenue uh within five years so
what's your thoughts about it
so I'm the principal engineer now
um
we could have picked someone in the
audience as a third person yeah sure
yeah we can do that maybe next time uh
so principal engineer uh you said we
need to double the revenue in the next
five days
it's going to be difficult it'll be
lucky to deploy the monolith once and
once in the next five years I'm really
not going to see how this is possible
from where we are right now it's looking
like a big challenge
yeah but you know they are very very
serious about it so well
um we really need to to accelerate the
way we develop things uh we need to to
increase our velocity a lot to meet
their expectations so
if you have any ideas I'm all ears I
know what you're saying boss but we've
we've been we've got a team of
developers who've been working in this
monolith making small bug fixes and
small BAU improvements and now you're
saying we need to completely redesign
the whole business break it apart
yeah yeah I'm not sure how we can get to
that High Velocity you're talking about
with the way we currently work and think
we need to just be ideas just don't seem
to exist in the company right now all
right
um so I might have an ID to start with
I've just read the team topology's book
uh when uh well they're speaking about
those stream online teams working
independently uh with fast flow so I
think that would be a good start a good
good starting point so how how can we or
how can we get there do you have any
ideas or together
well I mean the team's apologies book
has a lot of great ideas the concepts in
there make a lot of sense but the
challenge is how do you get there that's
what we need to focus on here how do we
get there
um but I have I have heard about this
thing called the DDD crew it's something
on GitHub where there's lots of ideas
and resources and blog posts and things
and they recommend we should use a
technique called event storming so I'm
going to go talk to my team and we're
going to try some event storming and see
where we end up cool let's do that okay
that's going to be the first section of
today's talk we're going to talk about
how to find domain boundaries with a
technique called event storming just a
quick
survey anyone here done event storming
before in your company
okay a few people um well we'll cover
the basics
and then everyone will be able to follow
along
so firstly very simple
starting point event storming is Simply
Orange Post-it notes
but there were a couple of important
rules and if you don't follow these
rules you'll upset some DDD people the
first rule is is timeline from left to
right and the second rule is it has to
be phrased in the past tense
so located near a scooter on the app
that's something that happened in the
past tense we're like we're telling a
story that happened in the past so we
have this timeline from left to right we
have all of these domain events
and we can have different flows things
happening in parallel options
um but it's not a flow chart where we're
quite specific in the details we're not
at a very abstract level
what makes these Post-it notes
interesting
it's not the color
it's not that they're phrased in the
past tense it's that you bring all of
your friends
and you do this together and your
friends can be other people you work
with who have the same job as you but
most importantly people who've got a
different job to you in this example
here we've got um that's my ear and
that's my hair I think that my hair was
a bit better cut than it was now but um
there's also a photographer over here
you don't need a photographer that was
just for this specific event and they
were having a special company get
together but we've got developers we've
got testers we've got product people
we've got customer success people
um
sure we might have had we had an
accountant in there as well there that
was interesting we had an accountant in
there so basically you bring all the
people who understand the different
parts of your business together and
you've got this very simple Post-It note
orange Post-It note format and you can
map out how your business works you have
lots of interesting conversations
people get to see different perspectives
people working in other teams people who
have different skills to you and it all
just comes together and you build this
it's a bit of a mess it looks messy but
it's not about it's not about the beauty
it's about putting all the knowledge
together and building a clear picture
so the technique itself is very useful
in isolation for a whole number of
purposes
but it's when you want to start thinking
about okay how do we organize our teams
into these value streams with fast flow
and how do we shape our software so we
can have teams working in different
parts of the code deploying
independently and not tripping over each
other
and that's where we can start to
organize these events into clusters so
in this example here
um this is from the domain of e-scooters
where you rent a scooter you know
scooters on the street scan the QR code
and start taking a journey so in this
example
um we've got an extract of the event
storm here and we've identified this
high-level Journeys domain this is quite
a big area of the company and within
that we've identified three potential
subdomains I'm searching for a scooter I
want to take a ride where's the nearest
scooter we then got the journey itself
this sub domain is responsible for
everything that happens whilst you're
taking a journey you might want to start
you want to end the journey you want to
pause the journey those kind of
responsibilities then we've got ride
completion some things that need to
happen at the end to
finish the journey trigger some next
steps check everything's working stuff
like that
so then once we've done that with the
event storm those boundaries that we
find they're kind of a starting point
event storming is quite high level so we
treat that as a starting point and not
as a finishing point
then we can apply these different checks
so here's an abstract example once
you've identified a potential subdomain
we can start to give it a name and we
can give it a description and then we
can start to move into the next level of
refinement and we can check do all of
the events in here
seem properly connected and cohesive or
are there some hidden domain Concepts
and potentially some hidden subdomains
in here or potentially this boundary we
found is wrong
so here's an example from a different
domain this is the pick up and drop off
subdomain for an online car dealership
so this sub domains purpose is that once
a customer has purchased a car on the
website
this sub domain is responsible for
ensuring that the car gets delivered to
the customer's house and the old car is
taken away
and by going through each of these
events and applying these checks and
refinements we can get a quick idea of
is this a good domain boundary or
have we got some deeper deeper issues or
design choices to think about here so in
this example
picked up new car from the warehouse
seems pretty related I think connected
back to the name connects back to the
purpose looks quite good arrived at the
customer's house yeah it's this next
step in the delivery process
offloaded the car yeah you need to
offload the car from the truck onto the
customer's driveway
we then got two question marks
um
gave the new owner a guide of the car so
if we think about this process when
we're delivering a car to a customer we
need to give them a guide of how it
works so it is it is part of this
exchanging process
but it feels outside of pick up and drop
off pick up and drop off has this
Logistics kind of feel where I was
giving an owner a guide over the car
we could imagine that there would be
business rules and data that would care
about these events together but maybe
not this one together so at this point
we just put a question mark there we're
not going to try and find the perfect
boundaries here we're just looking for
Identify some boundaries start assessing
it and refining it looking for ideas at
this point
and then once we've done that we can
start to apply some heuristics and
different ways to find boundaries
looking for different possibilities
it can be very difficult for people who
haven't done this before you know um a
lot of the workshops we do people are
like well what's a domain what's a sub
domain where do I start I don't you know
I've got all these events but you know I
just don't know where to start or even
begin it can be overwhelming the first
time you've done this so there are some
simple heuristics you can use to help
start taking those first steps this one
here is very simple if you're looking
for sub domains in your domain you map
out your process and then you consider
each step in the process as a sub domain
very easy starting point it's not always
going to be correct but it's a nice easy
starting point and very often it will
get you quite close to some of your
domain boundaries
the next heuristic you can then look at
is once you've identified those steps
you can look within them and say is
there anything common in those steps
that feels like it might belong together
in this simple example here we've got
these three sub domains which each
represent a step in the process
and you've got this notifications
concept appearing in all of them so we
decide yeah it feels like that should be
a separate thing so we'll pull out this
horizontal subdomain and those other
three can depend on this now
it's not always the case that this is
correct
um and it might be that in some
situations even notifications you might
want to keep it in those three it's all
about
looking for cohesion which we'll get to
in the next part of the talk so I'm not
going to go too much into that now
and then the opposite kind of heuristic
is where you see the same concept to
different places as I was talking about
but you keep it where we look for
different semantics
um this was something Scott Millett
pointed out to me about 10 years ago he
said
um you look for this concept in your
business
but people talk about it differently
they give it a different name in
different places so in this example a
very common example you've got some kind
of user or some kind of customer
when you talk to marketing people
they're using the word lead we're trying
to get this person to become a customer
to sign up to convert on our marketing
campaigns if you talk to someone in
Journeys they call them a rider this
person on a scooter taking a ride in
both of those different scenarios it's
the same physical person but we give
them a different name the way we talk
about them is different
and that different name is indicating a
different purpose over here the purpose
is getting them convert getting them to
convert over here the purpose is getting
them from A to B and so these different
ways of describing the same Concepts
yeah are giving us that clue that there
are different purposes which can be
organized separately
yeah right so so CTO yeah well um I
received a lot of excellent feedback
from people involved with those sessions
um those are even storming sessions
you've done and uh yeah and it it didn't
take that long to to to uh derive to
have this outcome so so very great job
continue well the first Workshop was a
bit
um you know some people were getting
used to the idea weren't sure where it
was going some people weren't engaging
that much so we it was a bit slow in the
first Workshop we had a couple of
Architects who
um didn't really enjoy this
collaborative Post-it notes way of
working but after the third Workshop you
know everyone was everyone was really
enjoying it and
we've identified what our domain
boundaries could be
could what what are you saying to me I
thought that it was it was it you you
did some even storming and you had your
domain boundaries what is this what's
next
well Advanced domains are very high
level technique um it's good for
exploring possibilities
um but it doesn't get into the low level
details we need to be confident that
this makes a good software architecture
and team boundaries so yeah what we need
to do now is we need to take these
domain boundaries we've identified and
we need to apply some reference use
cases and think about which parts of the
which of those sub domains would talk
together and which things might change
together and that will move us closer in
the direction we need to be going in all
right all right so okay let's take some
more time so let's let's see how uh
we can we can be more confident in those
uh different boundaries we found so
right now after the even storming
session says Nick said we have uh kind
of the first version of our boundaries
uh uh called it a draft so uh yeah we
need to be more confident uh and um
yeah we don't want to uh to start
building our architecture based on bets
in the future of course we want to uh uh
to make sure that those boundaries are
are the right ones so now it's quite a
bit uh fuzzy still so yeah
um we we need to um to test those
different boundaries against uh real uh
use case uh so
um that's something already that I've
already been uh said by Eric events uh
the person who invented domain driven
design so he created this uh Whirlpool
model of exploration uh in order to show
to people how to to build uh and to to
uh sorry to find out the right or the
right models for your uh your your
design but it totally applies to uh
finding the right boundaries as well
because it's it's just about well first
tell story ask as the main expert to
tell stories so that that's what they
were doing during the also installing
sessions and then hearing those stories
you will collect reference scenarios and
that's really really important because
then you will walk through those
different scenarios and make sure that
the boundaries you found are okay to
solve this this particular scenario if
not you you you might have to refine
those boundaries again and then
experiment a bit so that's why it's uh
so so those are cycles and refinement
Cycles again and again until you you are
quite confident in your the main
boundaries
um
during during those assessments as well
when you want to uh to be more confident
barrier boundaries you will think about
the coupling and bloody konanov has a
formula to
calculate actually the the coupling pain
and the Copic pain equals the strength
multiplied by volatility and multiplied
by the distance and so the strength is
how much effort you will have to uh to
make to make your components integrate
all together so there's a lot of
different coupling here involved
implementation model coupling kind of
stuff the volatility is
how often things are changing in your
different components and the distance is
how much cascading change you will have
to handle whenever something is changing
in your copying component so that's
something really interesting for teams
to keep in mind uh every time it will
work on domain boundaries and yeah what
is this coupling pane
between those different components
so yeah we spoke about this domain
message for modeling which is a pretty
easy tool to use whenever you want to
make sure your boundaries are right so
you can find it on the DDD crew GitHub
repository there's a lot of different
open source resources there so yeah
please have a look so first of all as
Eric Evan said you need to collect your
reference scenarios and then you pick
one important center for for from these
scenarios and it will start to to model
the flow using domain message for
modeling so you start with
an actor or system or or a subdomain and
then you create the message that need to
be sent from this actor or subdomain and
then you add the recipient and the
connection line between those two and
you see how things are interacting with
each other to fulfill this scenario and
you repeat until the scenario is
completed so seems quite easy so let's
take a next example here so this is an
example where you're placing an online
order when all items are in stock so as
I said this is one of our key scenarios
that we collected and we start with a
shopper which is uh who is the the actor
here involved in this process so first
thing that the Shopper is doing is that
he plays an order on the sales subdomain
and the sales subdomain is emitting an
even order placed and the billing
subdomain subscribe to this even so that
he knows when you need to charge the
credit card on the payment platform so
as soon as the credit card is charged
this billing subdomain will emit a
payment collected even that will be
interesting for the sale so that he can
update this the the state of the of the
sale and of course it will also be
interesting for notification subdomain
that will then send an email to The
Shopper back to the Shopper saying well
they're your order is placed so that's
how so you can start modeling the flow
of one particular scenario and as soon
as it's visualized you can try to find
out where where are my BD design issues
or spot design smell that you might have
um as a second step you can also add the
um the data that are at the payload of
those different messages uh but yeah
first of all yeah just just try to find
out the messages that that's the the
first thing to do and then the data so
as I said as soon as visualized
you can have uh you can start uh having
uh you can start reading those those
different uh diagrams and you can even
ask different teams uh to come and to uh
to challenge your different IDs and just
showing them those the simple diagrams
they can as as when you're reading code
I mean when you're reading code
sometimes you don't have to understand
it just to see that they are repeating
patterns and stuff like that so or
different levels of ifs or Loops
included so that that's the the kind of
stuff you can already uh without having
to understand the code you can you can
look at it and and have those pattern
visible that's exactly the same here you
can have different patterns visible
without having to know about the domain
so on the first example you may be uh
you might be thinking that well whenever
I do a command on this particular
subdomain it it needs to make four
different queries on another subdomains
too in order to make its job so well is
it okay uh wouldn't be too slow maybe
waiting for each queries uh to answer uh
so yeah that might be a design a design
problem here that you can spot easily on
the second example you might you might
think that the the sub domain in the
middle is just passing by comments to
another a third subdomain so is it
useful is it not so that that that
things that you can ask the team who
came out with this design and challenge
their their IDs
one of the things which is quite cool
with this tool is that it's very easy to
copy and paste uh one one of the your
diagram and make some changes and
compare different options you would have
so here uh we have
a discount decider that was uh on the
first option and then they decided maybe
to remove it and and to put the uh the
responsibility of decide whether uh we
need to apply a discount or not maybe in
another subdomain so you have different
options here and then you can you can
decide uh the pros and cons of both
options and and and try trying one first
based on the the feedback you will have
from the team or other teams
um here's a case study uh from a company
I worked with they wanted to rebuild
their um accounting a big monolith and
they've already decided to go first with
this fixed asset module so one of the
key scenarios we identified for this
fixed asset module is the the fixed
asset ass set sales and so we we try to
find out what were the subdomains
involved and and after they're even
storming they came out with three or
four different subdomains for this fixed
asset module and uh yeah so it was
really really fine-grained but as its
fine grain you see a lot of different
messages
involved and so uh yeah they try to
think about maybe make it a bit more
simple so they as a second step as a the
the next refinement the uh they thought
that well it's it's well you don't you
don't have any Revelation uh without
having a sales so those two things are
really tied together so we need to put
in the same subdomain so the integrated
the the sales and the regulation
calculation on the same uh subdomain and
that's uh when they were thinking it
again and again as a step three
um they came out with this where they oh
well actually the sales is a behavior of
the fixed assets so we need to put this
behavior and those responsibility in the
fixed asset submodel and subdomain and
then the Computing would be done in
another subdomain where you would have
the depreciation calculation and the
Revelation calculation so you see it's
um
it's really refining those boundaries
and sometimes well you will have big sub
domains that you would need to uh split
because they are handling too much
responses but sometimes it's the other
way around maybe you will have two two
small boundaries and you will have to uh
maybe uh put those things back together
how to make a bigger subdomain
so um in the end well this tool is very
easy to use and it will help you to
identify the interaction and the
dependencies between the audio
subdomains and the thing is that you
will really be more confident in those
boundary uh and you because you will
validate uh the the the boundaries you
found through real use cases and you
will try to see how things are
attracting to fulfill a particular
scenario so we will get at the end
better of the defined boundaries and
that's what we want so yeah would lead
to lower coupling and I will tell you
how your systems communicate
so back to our role playing so I'm still
the CDO and
Mr principal engineer so how did it go
did you finish all the flow is it okay
right now can we start coding
I think we've had some great workshops I
think we've got much more into the
details we can start seeing how those
domain boundaries might turn into
software boundaries got quite a strong
idea on that so
I would say yeah we've got some
we've got a
we've got like an idea we think could
work but the team's still a bit
uncertain at the moment I think we're
almost ready to take the first step cool
so um
we can now maybe focus on the first
iteration and start maybe uh coding
something that would be sending a great
message to the board they will be very
happy to see that we're starting uh the
new the new system yeah yeah it's going
to be a long journey these things don't
happen overnight Mr CTO let's not
let's not stop promising too many things
but I think we're ready to start making
the first step breaking up that first
piece out of our monolith
um what I think what we need to do is
just bring the group together
reflect on the workshops we've had put
all the information in a clear place and
just does this make sense let's do it
and uh I think I found a tool that can
help us to do that cool what is this
it's called the bounded context canvas
it's it's a tool that helps you just to
make sure that your domain boundaries
represent a really tightly closed
um context
up please go
okay so that's going to be the final
thing we're going to talk about today
um so technique as we talked about it's
a canvas just helps you to get from that
fuzzy we've talked about lots of things
to here's a clearer idea does it make
sense
so as Max was talking about with message
flow modeling we look at different
scenarios different use cases we look at
different coupling and what we want to
do now is try and end up with an
overview of a particular service you
want to build in our software a
particular part of our monolith so the
canvas has these different areas
I'm not going to go over them now and
bore you to death because that would be
too much but I'll give you a quick
overview there's also a new version of
the canvas which has even more things on
it so nice little treat for you to look
at in the break so basically what's the
name what's the purpose strategic
classification is touching on how
important is this to the business and
when we're making these transitions in
our architecture
we don't want to spend months
refactoring parts of the software that
don't really have much business value so
that's about capturing the importance
domain roles
I'm not going to talk about that now
it's it's a simple thing but it's hard
to explain and then
down the bottom here we have
messages coming in
messages going out things that we did in
message flow modeling and in the middle
we have business rules and domain
terminology
effectively if you've seen CRC cards
from the 90s it's kind of that but with
DDD terminology the commands events and
queries
so here's an example we've got this
booking service and it handles all of
the bookings and it's highly
customizable
so as we've laid all of these things out
here
um as Max was talking about very often
you can just see patterns and in this
example we've got words like create
updates and delete those don't really
sound like terms in add domain here
um you know what when when I update an
order for example what's the what's the
user trying to update on the order the
address the price the line items maybe
there's some hidden domain Concepts in
there that would be better modeled
explicitly and this is also a warning
sign that if you're if you're planning
to implement this in software maybe you
don't understand the domain well enough
yet if you're not able to describe it
more clearly
at the bottom
uh well where do we start on this one
we've created a rules engine for the
booking system
we wanted to give business all of the
tools they needed to not have to wait
for developers to make changes but maybe
that's a bit Overkill here maybe there's
a simpler solution than building this
complex rules engine so that's what's
jumping out over here and also if we
look at this as an overall perspective
um maybe those two things can be
separately whenever we create a canvas
like this and we get these different
clusterings we can always ask
is that bit and that bit could they be
separate things so then we start asking
are there business rules and data which
are common across these flows down here
and these Flows at the top
uh one more example
um this is this example is touching on
naming naming's pointing us at something
a bit more fundamental in the design
here we've got the word management now
the word management doesn't really
doesn't really exclude much so anything
can end up here it's like your utils
folder in your code base and that's
exactly what we can see here we've got
lots of different collaborators
and we've got lots of different kinds of
messages over here we're talking about
get the location of a scooter and check
out the scooter okay that seems
reasonably cohesive we're then talking
about forecasting and demand and then
we're talking about Hardware errors down
here so
too many responsibilities basically and
when we put this all together
it jumps out to us if we were
if we were trying to have this
conversation
and people might feel like Fleet
Management makes sense it's a good idea
it's not until you visualize everything
that some people realize oh actually
it's a bit more complex than I thought
um as I was talking about with naming
there's this really useful concept I
don't know who came up with this quote
if you find them send them my way but
basically generic names attract generic
Behavior
and specific names make it very clear
when you've got a responsibility that
doesn't live there so in this example
we've got
um business property tax management
anything about business property tax can
live here that word management doesn't
exclude something but the register does
that's a specific aspect if we now talk
about
um other bits of business property tax
that wouldn't be related to the register
it would be obvious that they don't
belong here
I should have picked a simple example
for this one and then finally
um just some tips here when you map
things out on a canvas here are some
kind of things to look for and you're
looking at the overall design so just a
number of dependencies
um if you've got lots of collaborators
on each side already that's just a
warning sign a lot of interactions here
a lot of coupling maybe there's
something fundamental and then challenge
them as Max was talking about earlier
there's a concept from vladic conanov's
book is coupling book he's talking about
the pain so we can't remove every
dependency but if we go through each
dependency on the canvas and we can
assess what's the pain of this
dependency and what's the strength
what's the volatility and what's the
distance of these two components and
then we can decide we've got this this
service has 10 dependencies these two
are very painful let's redesign it to
move those two and we're happy to keep
the other eight dependencies
um logical ownership of data is an
interesting one
um so whenever you see a service that's
getting data from somewhere else
always ask the question should it be
getting that data from that service if
you're trying to get the location of the
scooter from the CMS
why why are we getting the location of a
scooter from the CMS that that should
not be coming from that we've got some
weird design issues here
and then chatting us whenever you've got
two collaborators and there's lots going
back and forth between them like in
Max's example with those four queries
again that's something that can jump out
to you and you can zoom into that
further
yeah I think we've done aren't we yeah
what else can we say
I don't know
um mostly couples software architectures
so that's that's the aim of all this so
uh uh the process we we just thought
about uh help you to define those uh
those uh boundaries and you need to keep
in mind that it's not a rigid
methodology or any so new Silver Bullet
uh whatever you can adapt it to your
context of course uh if you have other
tools that you're already using within
your team that that that
aim at having the same the same kind of
output that well yeah please keep on
using them
um there's a lot of different tools that
you can see also on the DDD crap GitHub
repositories there's a lot of examples
uh there so please have a look it's
great so it's a an iterative process
made of refinement cycle so that
whatever where it's getting grades is
that well you work on that you you've
reckoned that and then you you uh you
refine it and yeah having having yeah
please also ask different teams to have
a look to what you you've done to uh so
they they can they can do some some uh
visual pattern reading and and maybe uh
try to find out uh different uh uh
different design smells or whatever uh
in your in your in your design so uh
yeah so it's it's really uh about uh
getting deeper
um into uh the domain knowledge and also
uh getting more confidence in your uh
boundaries
yeah just to touch on one of those
topics one of the key if all of this
kind of stuff is new to that new to you
that we're talking about here uh one of
the feelings or one of the thoughts you
might have a lot of people have in this
situation is
they're looking for a recipe
um so you're telling me if I do event
storming and then message flow modeling
and then the canvas then my monolith
will be fully decoupled and we can just
that's it um but really it's not about
that step-by-step process you can do
these techniques in any order you go
from one technique to the other I think
the key thing is as I talked about at
the start getting people together for
those collaborative workshops all of
these techniques we've talked about are
about the collaboration aspect
it's easy to use the word collaboration
but the reason it's important
is because you want to have these ideas
and skills spread throughout your
company
because we don't just simply go from a
monolith to a decoupled software
architecture that's a very iterative
process we might get our boundaries
wrong
so we want everyone who's working in
this area
to know how to use these techniques and
to know how to use and to have these
skills so that that continuous Evolution
can happen and when you use
collaborative techniques you spread the
knowledge you spread the skills and
everyone's able to be part of that
continuous Evolution process yeah and as
our friend Michael ammoshoff is saying
is that you don't discuss anything that
isn't visualized so please if you have
different options to discuss please copy
and paste make changes and and discuss
those those different things that you
can visualize so yeah it's important to
visualize stuff a bunch of links that
you can have a look
to know more about all these so yeah we
mentioned the DDD crew GitHub repository
there's a lot of different uh
repositories there even storming cheat
sheet we talk about domain message for
modeling we have this this domain driven
design starter modeling process which is
a a big a way bigger than what we uh
talk about here today
um the whirlpool process of model
exploration from Eric events the latest
DDD book uh released by athletic on and
off if you want to know more about DDD
so yeah that's a pretty good read
and uh I think we want bore you anymore
so hopefully we didn't bore you too much
thanks for coming thanks for coming
um we have some four questions I think
yeah we have uh 10 minutes or five
lemons four questions uh if you have
some yeah please uh come to the mic
there so it's recorded and then it will
be easier for everyone
yeah stand up
bounded context canvases
um looks cool looks interesting my
concern is is how documentation heavy
will that end up making things keeping
in mind an agile way of not having tons
of documentation
honestly about that now
yeah so the canvas I wouldn't recommend
that as necessarily A documentation tool
some people do like to do that it's
mostly as a design tool in the moment
you might keep it as an artifact and say
at this point in time this is how we saw
it but yeah I'd be very careful
um you know any documentation that you
have to keep up to date manually and
there's an effort involved we should be
coming out of date you spend a lot of
time documenting things so I think all
of the usual documentation rules apply
wherever possible any documentation
that's informational that describes the
existing state of the system we want to
be able to generate that automatically
um we're not quite there at the moment
there are some there are some people who
are working on that and there are some
tools in this space so
um yeah overall I would say yeah don't
think of it as a documentation tool
maybe as a snapshot as a point in time
only but mostly as a tool for
getting people together and making a
decision does this make sense should we
implement it
I would even throw it away afterwards
but yeah I would add that as you said
it's a snapshot and that would be a
great idea to put in your ADR if you are
doing ADR architecture decision records
so whenever you take any decision of
your of your uh about your architecture
you can trust that Trace that into a
simplify and you could do this snapshot
of your bounded context count bus at
this time and then describe the uh the
situation
um in your edrs and you can you can see
how it evolved and and what was the
context before when people took that
decision
um and yeah for those tools that uh well
as as Nick said the only up-to-date
documentation is always the code so uh
whenever you can you can build out your
documentation uh out uh from your code
that that's way better so I would
recommend to have a read that living
documentation book by a Serial and uh
living documentation is really the way
to go if you if you want to have
up-to-date documentation that can be uh
build up like when in your nightly bills
or whatever you can create your
architecture diagrams your
specifications whatever if you take
those
recommendations from them from the book
yep
what time was it by the way
what time the book oh no no no uh it's
uh 47. okay yeah we have time for a
couple more questions yeah I think if
anyone has a question
okay so I'll replay the question
um your question was when we're doing
event storming
um do we capture the frequency of events
and uh what was your example sorry
yeah it's a good question
um in general when you're doing event
storming it depends on the level of
abstraction you're working at if you're
working at a very high level there might
be a lot of details that you don't
include if you've got like if you're
doing an event storming for like 10
teams you can't get into the details of
every every event that's relevant to all
of those 10 teams
so what tends to happen is we do
workshops at different levels and there
are different kinds of event storming as
well so
a typical big picture high level session
would help you to identify possible
domain boundaries and then you would
have follow-up workshops to get more
into details where you flesh out
the things that weren't represented at a
higher level and you can either you even
use process modeling Advanced storming
to get even further into the details
but what Alberto brandolini the inventor
or if you want something is also saying
is that even storming is his bids are
but you can put everything on top uh
expect pineapples sorry Nick and yeah so
if you want to put some metrics
information you could do that as well so
you can add anything you want that will
add some some value to your installing
so yeah please add those information and
we are very into that as well so we we
have a color dedicated to metrics like
when you have different paths maybe you
it's important to know whether this Edge
case is only five percent of the case
well you might not spend that much time
on it because it's not necessarily uh
big but uh yeah if it's those if if
you're earning your money in those five
Persons Of course that's the other way
around so yeah please add those
information to your even swimming
whenever it's uh valuable
yep any more question
someone
yep
and then you realize you got it wrong
it's fine to go through its process
you'd expect to be wrong
[Laughter]
so are there other techniques
that you would then use once you've
actually got some codes to put out into
sub domain or would you
iterate over the techniques that we've
seen here
um so if I understand you correctly
you've identified a potential split from
the monolith and the next step is how to
break it out on a technical level or
you've already broken it out and you
realize oh dear this isn't how we should
have broken out
um well I think a lot of effort goes
into like preventing that from happening
where possible um but it does it does
happen for various reasons
um
I guess one of the key things is
thinking about the teams that are
earning the different pieces and they're
still working closely together so when
you first break something out it always
makes sense for the team that owns that
new piece to be to have that ability to
work with teams that still own parts of
the monolith so there's some that's the
distance we talked about in vladox
Formula what's the distance between
those two teams if the monolith teams in
one country and that seems in a
completely separate country and they're
not talking
um
it's you know they might not even feel
comfortable to say we've made a mistake
here that's going to try and make this
solution work whereas if those teams
work closely together on an
organizational level
they're more likely to figure out how
can we
how can we evolve things how can we work
closely together maybe something that
we've taken out should be owned by that
team so it's an organizational aspect
um
uh that's all I can think of really
right now just um yeah preparing to be
wrong making sure that if something does
go wrong the teams can work together and
figure things out
um any anything you're thinking of
you're asking about techniques right
specific techniques perhaps I will go
try to go back to the
uh Eric Evans Whirlpool model of
exploration when he where that's that
one yeah here make mistakes it's written
down so it's part of the the process
actually it's to realize that maybe you
you'll have uh some some some
misunderstandings that that leads to to
mistakes in your modeling so uh yeah
that's why spending a bit of time on
this and refining and and and try to
find out valeries being more confident
in those uh uh it's it's it's way better
and it's way better to do that up front
of course because as you said whenever
it's started it's quite hard to change
but uh yeah it's part of the part of the
process making mistake so uh you need to
be in an organization also that allows
you to make mistake and experiment so of
course without it it will be difficult
of course yeah a lot of companies do end
up in that situation at a distributed
model of the microservices
I'm just struggling to think of here's
something very specific you could do to
fix it in general we might want to go
through this process again and figure
out based on what we know now what would
be the ideal boundaries
um so these techniques would still apply
as you're trying to figure out what's
the right step forward yep um I guess
that yeah the complexity is always going
to be
getting from your current architecture
to the new one that's always going to be
the difficult bit and all very
specifically on how you've shaped it how
your teams organize the tech stack
you're using
um so I can't think of too much in that
space that would be generic advice
but I think in terms of the techniques
um yeah you could reuse them to figure
out we've currently got this
architecture that we feel is wrong we've
got this one piece that feels wrong how
could we figure out what it should be on
a conceptual level
yeah I can't think of anything else
about that sorry
I think we're done oops Yeah 55. okay
thanks everyone if you've got any
questions at any point feel free to
email us and stuff always happy to chat
and I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you see you
foreign